- The only reason I could
deal with the pressure
on Star Wars is 'cause I
love making that movie.
And if it didn't work, of
course I would have been
crushed, but I wasn't doing
it because it was a job.
But most people talk
about writing screenplays
but don't actually write them.
The people who write them,
you're already in like,
the top 10% because you've
actually written it.
10 years ago, if we wanted to do that,
we'd have to kill a stunt man.
We'd actually... (audience laughs)
- Hello, believe nation.
It's Evan.
My one word is believe,
and I believe in people
more than they believe in
themselves, and my sincere hope
is that if you see in
yourself what I see in you,
you'll be able to change the planet.
So to help you on your journey,
today we're going to learn
from film director and
producer, JJ Abrams,
and my take on his top
10 rules for success.
Rule number six is my personal favorite,
and I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
Also, as you're watching,
if you hear something
that really resonates
with you, please leave it
down in the comments below,
and put quotes around it
so other people can be
inspired by it as well.
And if you leave it within
the first couple hours
of this video going live,
you have a chance to win
one of two daily prizes.
(swooshes)
(sweeping instrumental music)
(beeps)
- Given all the
opportunities that are there
in the world, to try
and figure out the thing
that actually makes you want
to get up in the morning,
the thing that you actually love.
I just know that if I
weren't lucky enough to have
been given the opportunity
to write a movie or a show
or direct anything or produce anything,
I would still go home from
whatever that day job is,
and I would try to do
it because I love it,
not because I really want to
make a certain amount of money.
It's great to be comfortable.
It can be dangerous to be comfortable.
But it's great to be comfortable.
But I just feel like if you
can figure out the thing
that makes you tick.
Find that thing.
And the other thing I would say, I guess,
is a lot of young people, I
find, are under such pressure.
There's a kind of sense
of it's all or nothing,
which I think is really unfair.
Meaning, I don't know if
it's the media and the way
things are presented or if
it's because there's so much
success that is celebrated in society.
But there is a sense.
I've heard enough that I
feel like, I haven't thought
of this 'til now, that
it is a kind of theme
that young people feel
like if they don't know
what they're born to do,
that they're somehow broken.
And I think that it needs
to be looked at differently,
which is it means that if
you don't know that thing,
it means that every
door is the possibility.
It's a beautiful thing.
So I just feel like I would
say don't stress yourself out.
You know, the only reason I
could deal with the pressure
on Star Wars is because I
loved making that movie,
and if it didn't work, of course,
I would have been crushed,
but I wasn't doing it
because it was a job.
And if you can find that thing
and deal with the pressure
of maybe not making the amount of money
that you would like to yet or
not getting into the company
that you would like to
yet or not having success
with your startup yet.
These are all things that
I think you can swallow
if the thing you're doing speaks to you.
Because the resources have
been so limited for so long,
there are a lot of people
who would say, God,
if I only had access to a
camera, I would make a movie.
There's a lot of talk about.
I remember when I was in
college, I would spend
most of my time in my
room writing screenplays,
really bad screenplays, but
I was in my room doing that
when I probably should have
been studying or something.
There were a lot of people, I
remember, at parties who would
talk about writing and that
they wanted to be a writer.
But I always noticed that
they were out every time
that I would happen to go
out, they would always be out.
And they, I just know that
they were people who would talk
about what they would do if,
but they're not actually doing anything.
And so it's a lot easier to
actually write a screenplay
than you think it is.
It might not be good.
Most people talk about writing screenplays
but don't actually write them.
The people who write them,
you're already like in,
you know, the top 10%
'cause you've written it.
A, I love the movie Star Wars so much.
I love the original trilogy.
I was 11-years-old when
I saw the first one.
It had a profound impact on
me, so the idea of getting
so close to something kind
of scared me a little bit.
And also, I'd been working
on a bunch of things,
and Katie, my wife, had, you
know, plans with her family
to go away for a little while.
- (laughs) Really?
- Yeah, and then Kathleen Kennedy called.
She was like, do you
want to make Star Wars?
And I was like, I said, no, thank you.
But then she said, can we talk in person?
I said, of course, and
she came in, and we met.
And all we had to do was
start talking about it.
I just felt myself, like--
- [Jimmy] You got carried
away with yourself.
- Yeah, I did.
If I, Katie said afterwards,
the meeting, I talked about it.
She said, if you pass them
up, you'll probably regret it
for the rest of your life.
You should really consider it.
A lot of times writers will
say, I'm working on this thing,
but I don't know if
anyone's going to like it.
It feels sort of like this
boring thing that I love.
You know?
And it's amazing how
often that boring thing
that you love becomes a sensation.
And I think the key is to do that.
Once you start working
on something saying,
oh, they'll like this.
This'll be cool for them.
I mean, literally, we
were working on this book,
you know, and we were
like, this is insane.
And it's never going to, you know, happen.
And we'll see.
And to approach something
with a kind of excitement
that is shared in this weird
way where you just know
it makes you happy.
And then to see it on the New
York Times Bestseller List.
We're like, oh, my god.
Like, that's nuts.
We never would've dreamed it.
It's really a result of,
you know, having an idea
that stayed with me and that I loved,
but that Lindsey felt like,
oh, this could be something.
Finding Doug who took
it and said, oh, my god.
What about this?
And it was like, at each stage
we were sort of, you know,
just turned on by what it
could be but never thinking,
oh, this is going to work
really well because actually,
we were thinking, oh, my god.
No publisher's ever going
to be able to pull this off,
you know, which Little, Brown
and Mohawk Books totally did.
And even if they do,
who's going to want it?
And it's been nice to
have it received warmly
and very unexpected, frankly.
But the answer is just to work on things
that you actually care
about wherever you can
and to not try and think too
hard about what it's going to
be like when it goes out into the cold,
hard reality of the world.
You know when you're watching a movie,
and you hear a line,
and it feels like, oh,
they thought that was going
to be a line in the trailer?
Like, you just know that on
the set, someone was like,
oh, that's a trailer moment
because it doesn't feel real
necessarily in life, but it was just like,
oh, that's a great sound bite.
That's a great thing.
There's a visual equivalent of that.
And you got to be really
careful 'cause sometimes
I'll think, oh, this
is one of the moments,
and then, you end up
doing it, and the truth is
it ends up feeling posed.
It just doesn't feel authentic.
I try for those sometimes.
They never seem to work.
I think that the key
for any of this stuff,
and you know, whether we've
accomplished it or not
is up to the audience,
but I think that the key
to any movie working, certainly
a movie called Star Trek,
which could be seen as campy,
is finding authenticity.
And whether it's in a little
nuance, a little moment,
a character exchange, a look, a glance,
or a huge plot point, there's
something, for me, that is,
if I don't really understand
what's going on, if I can't
really get into or under the
skin of these characters,
none of the spectacle is going to matter.
It's a very strange thing.
I was at a baseball game
recently with Stephen King,
and he was telling me
about this idea that he has
for this story he wants to write.
And he was talking about it in a way, yes,
what he was telling me was terrifying.
(audience laughs)
And it was the way that he
was telling it that was so
incredible to me because
he was saying it like this.
He was like, well, I know, I'm
not going to say what the story
was 'cause he would then kill me.
But he said, I know that
there's this person who,
and he started talking
about that, and I know
that they're, and listening
to the way he was saying
what he knew, 'cause
he hadn't worked on it.
He hadn't sat down and outlined it.
He hadn't, there was no strategy to it.
But it was like he was just his intuition
of what it should be, and
he knew enough to know
he's got something to
take that leap of faith.
And any creation, any act of
creation, is a leap of faith.
And I just think that it's
part of, the fun of it
is knowing that it may work.
(laughs)
And he, the other thing I want
to say, which is years ago,
I was working with James
L. Brooks, who did some
of my favorite movies and TV
shows, and this is 20 some
years ago, but I remember,
I was reading a book
about how he wrote Broadcast
News and how he structured it
and how at a certain point
in act two, there was
this transition and at the
end of act two to act three
he had done this, and all this stuff.
And I said to him one
day, I was like, Jim, so
I just want to ask you
something about Broadcast News.
When you did that transition
from the second act
to the third act, did you know that Jane
was going to do this, you
know, and he was like,
what are you talking about?
Well, that thing.
He's like, what transition?
What I realized was, 'cause
it was all (host laughs)
was that the writer of this
book on how to write screenplays
had deconstructed what
James L. Brooks had written
and had written about how he had done it.
But he hadn't done it that way.
He just wrote and told a
story that he believed in,
and he found it.
But you can always
deconstruct, as companies do
left and right, what you
make, and they can go,
oh, this is what they did.
And this is why they did it.
And they can deconstruct
it and then try and,
but they're already starting
from a place of artifice,
of duplication as opposed
to a place that I know you.
And I know how you do it,
of authenticity and I feel
this thing that should exist.
And you take that leap of
faith that it may work.
The thing that I think was
it's not as much advice
as it was given, per say, but
what I kind of learned early
on is that your voice is as
important as anyone else's.
You may not always be right,
and you shouldn't be cocky about it.
But there's a kind of,
I felt like I needed to learn
that the ideas that I had
were as good as anyone
else's ideas, you know.
Certainly not better, and
I love the collaboration,
so it wasn't like I felt
like it was a battle.
But it's one of those things
that I think it's good
to be reminded, or if you
don't know it at all, be told
that that thing that you feel
(sighs) if you really feel it,
other people do, too, and
that's something that is
to be, you know, mined
and to be celebrated.
The truth is that if the
master you're serving
is the project, is the idea,
is the book, in this case,
being territorial or, you
know, if I were to, you know,
not be willing to share
this idea, I'd be nowhere
near this room right now, and
I would not be talking to you.
The whole point of it is if
there's an idea that's worth
doing, and if you think
you can do it yourself?
Great.
You know, you should do it, but no movie
gets made with one person.
No television show does.
And while a lot of books do,
I knew this book wouldn't,
just myself, and the
collaboration was really something
that was born out of a
discussion with Lindsey Weber.
And in talking about it
with her, the idea of like,
let's find someone that we
can collaborate on this thing.
And so my name is on the book.
I'm already getting too
much credit as it is.
The truth is that Doug is the
author of record of this book.
And my involvement, yes,
I had the original idea,
and they probably felt that
it was, you know, easier
to go out and sort of sell the
book if I was a part of that,
but the experience of doing it was
such a wonderful experience.
The collaboration was
so great, and any time,
I'm sure you've felt this
if you've ever collaborated
with people in this way.
When someone is better
than you are at something,
and they inspire you,
your ideas get better.
And then you're suddenly
saying, wait a minute.
How about this?
I never would have though
of it, but what about this?
You know, I will say,
I'm working right now
with Lawrence Cazden,
you know, on a script.
And working with him as been such a joy
because he will throw out
ideas that in a million years
I would never have thought
of that are patently better
than any idea I would have had that day.
And all the sudden, he ups my
game because he is so good.
And I felt the same exact
thing working with Doug.
He brought to me and to Lindsey
a world that took a notion
that could have gone
any direction, and I think
just elevated it completely.
So I embrace the collaboration.
I don't care who has the best idea
when we're working on a movie.
I always tell the crew,
whoever has the idea,
if there's a moment that you
think will make this moment
better, more authentic, funnier,
scarier, more interesting,
please share it.
When I talk to the kind rep
from TED, and I said, listen.
What should I talk about?
He said, don't worry about it.
Just be profound.
(audience laughs)
And I took enormous comfort in that,
so thank you if you're here.
(audience laughs)
I was trying to think,
what do I talk about?
It's a good question.
Why do I do so much stuff
that involves mystery,
and I started trying to figure it out.
I started thinking about why
do I do any of what I do,
and I started thinking
about my grandfather.
I loved my grandfather.
Harry Kelvin was his
name, my mother's father.
He died in 1986.
He was an amazing guy.
And one of the reasons he was
amazing, after World War II,
he began an electronics
company that he started
selling surplus parts,
kits to schools and stuff.
So he had this incredible curiosity.
As a kid, I saw him come
over to me with radios
and telephones and all sorts of things,
and he'd open them up.
He'd unscrew them, and
reveal the inner workings,
which many of us, I'm
sure, take for granted.
But it's an amazing gift
to give a kid, to open up
this thing and show how
it works and why it works
and what it is.
He was the ultimate
deconstructor in many ways,
and my grandfather was the
kind of guy who would not only
take things apart, but he got
me interested in all sorts
of crafts, like, you know,
printing, like the letter press.
I'm obsessed with printing.
I'm obsessed with silk
screening and book binding
and box making, and when I
was a kid, I was always like,
taking apart boxes and stuff.
And last night in the hotel,
I took apart the Kleenex box,
and I was just looking at it.
And I'm telling you, (audience laughs)
it's a beautiful thing.
I swear to God.
When you look at the box, and
you sort of see how it works.
Reeves is here, and I met
him years ago at a book fair.
He does pop up books, and
I'm obsessed with like,
engineering of paper.
But like the scoring of
it, the printing of it,
where the thing gets glued, you know,
the registration marks for the ink.
I just love boxes.
My grandfather was sort of
the guy who, you know, kind of
got me into all sorts of these things.
He would also supply me with tools.
He was this amazing encourager,
this patron sort of,
to make stuff, and he
got me a Super 8 camera
when I was 10-years-old.
And in 1976, that was
sort of an anomaly to be
a 10-year-old kid that
had access to a camera.
And, you know, he was so generous.
I couldn't believe it.
He wasn't doing it entirely
without some manipulation.
I mean, I would call
him, and I would be like,
listen, Grandpa.
I really need this camera.
You don't understand.
This is like, I want to make movies.
I'll get invited to TED one day.
This is like--
(audience laughs)
And my grandmother was the
greatest 'cause she'd be like,
you know, like, she'd get on the phone.
And she'd be like, Harry,
it's better than the drugs.
(audience laughs)
He should be doing this.
She was fantastic.
(audience laughs)
So I found myself getting this
stuff thanks to her assist,
and suddenly, you know,
I had a synthesizer
when I was 14-years-old.
This kind of stuff.
And it let me make things, which to me,
was sort of the dream.
He humored my obsessions with
other things, too, like magic.
The thing is we'd go to his
magic store in New York City
called Lou Tannen's Magic.
It was this great magic store.
It was like crappy little
building in Midtown,
but you'd be in the elevator.
The elevator would open.
There's be this little small magic store.
You'd be in the magic store,
and it was just a magical place.
So I got all these sort of magic tricks.
Oh, here, I'll show
you, this kind of thing.
So it's be like, you know, right,
which is good, but now I can't move.
Now, I have to, the rest of
the thing, I'm like this.
Oh, wow, look at my computer over there.
Anyway--
(audience laughs)
So one of the things that I bought
at the magic store was this,
Tannen's Mystery Magic Box.
The premise behind the Mystery
Magic Box was the following.
15 dollars buys you 50
dollars worth of magic,
which is a savings.
(audience laughs)
Now, I bought this decades
ago, and I'm not kidding.
If you look at this you'll
see it's never been opened,
but I've had this forever.
Now I was looking at this.
It was in my office as it
always in on the shelf,
and I was thinking, why
have I not opened this?
And why have I kept it?
Because I'm not a pack rat.
I don't keep everything.
But for some reason, I
haven't opened this box.
And I felt like there
was a key to this somehow
in talking about something at
TED that I haven't discussed
before and bored people elsewhere.
So I thought maybe there's
something with this.
I started thinking about
it, and like, there was
this giant question mark.
I love the design for what
it's worth of this thing.
And I started thinking,
why haven't I opened it.
And I realized that I haven't opened it
because it represents
something important to me.
It represents my grandfather.
Am I allowed to cry at TED?
- [Audience Member] Yes.
- No, I'm not going to cry.
(audience laughs)
But the (laughs) the thing is it
represents infinite possibility.
It represents hope.
It represents potential.
And what I love about this
box, and what I realized
I sort of do in whatever it is that I do,
is I find myself drawn
to infinite possibility
and that sense of potential.
I realize that mystery is
the catalyst for imagination.
Now, it's not the most
groundbreaking idea,
but when I started to think
that maybe there are times
when mystery is more
important than knowledge
I started getting interested in this.
So I started thinking about
Lost and stuff that we do,
and I realized, oh, my God, mystery boxes
are everywhere in what I do.
And how in the creation of
Lost, Damon Lindelof and I
who created the show with
me, we were basically tasked
with creating this series that we had
very little time to do.
We had 11 and a half weeks
to write it, cast it,
crew it, shoot it, cut
it, post it, turn it into
a two hour pilot, so it
was not a lot of time.
And that sense of possibility,
what could this thing be?
There was no time to develop it.
I'm sure you're all familiar
with those people who tell you
what you can't do and
what you should change.
And there was no time for
that, which is kind of amazing.
And so we did the show,
and for those of you
who haven't seen it or don't
know, I'm going to show you
this one clip from the pilot to show you
some stuff that we did.
(engine whines)
(dramatic suspenseful music)
- Help!
Please, help me!
- All right, get him out of
here away from the engine.
Get him out of here.
(engine whines)
(screams)
- Please, I'm having contractions.
- How many months pregnant are you?
- I'm only eight months.
- How far apart are they coming?
- I don't know.
It just happened.
(screams)
- [Man] Hey, hey, hey, get away from--
- What?
(explodes)
- Now 10 years ago, if
we wanted to do that,
we'd have to kill a stunt man.
We'd actually...
(audience laughs)
It would be harder.
It would take, take two would be a bitch.
(audience laughs)
So the amazing this was we
were able to do this thing,
and part of that was the amazing
availability of technology
knowing we could do anything.
I mean, we could never have done that.
We might have been able to write it.
We wouldn't have been able
to depict it like we did,
and so part of the amazing thing for me is
in the creative process,
technology is like
mindblowingly inspiring to me.
I realize that that blank
page is a magic box.
You know, it needs to be filled
with something fantastic.
I used to have the Ordinary People script.
I'd flip through it.
The romance of the
script was amazing to me.
It would inspire me.
I wanted to try and fill pages
with the same kind of spirit
and thought and emotion
that that script did.
So that, I love Apple computers.
I'm obsessed.
So like, the Apple
computer, the PowerBook,
this computer right
here, it challenges me.
It basically, says, you
know, what are you going
to write worthy of me?
Like I feel this.
(audience laughs)
I'm compelled.
And I often am like, dude, today, I'm out.
I got nothing.
(audience laughs)
So there's that.
In terms of the content of
it, you look at stories.
You think, well, what are
stories but mystery boxes.
There's a fundamental question, in TV,
the first act is called the teaser.
It's literally the teaser.
It's the big question.
So you're drawn into it.
Then, of course, there's another question.
And it goes on and on and on.
I mean, look at like, Star Wars.
You've got the Droids.
They meet the mysterious woman.
Who's that?
We don't know.
Mystery box.
Then you meet Luke Skywalker.
He gets the Droid.
You see the holographic image.
You learn, oh, it's a message.
She wants to, you know,
find Obi-Wan Kenobi.
He's her only hope, but who
the hell is Obi-Wan Kenobi?
Mystery box.
So then you go, and he meets Ben Kenobi.
Ben Kenobi's uncle is Obi-Wan Kenobi.
Holy shit, you know, so it
keeps its (audience laughs),
have you guys not seen that?
(audience laughs)
It's huge.
- Who is Stephen King?
I mean, honestly.
- He is-- (audience laughs)
- We'll edit this out.
Just... (laughs)
- No, he's the greatest.
I, I--
- [Jimmy] No, he's scary, right?
He's frightening.
- Well, he's got a very, he's a obviously,
one of the most brilliant
minds of all time.
- Has he murdered anyone? (laughs)
(audience laughs)
- Well, I met him many, many years ago.
We were doing the show
Lost, and Damon Lindelof
and Carlton Cuse and I
went to Maine to have
a meeting with him for this magazine.
- [Jimmy] Oh, no.
- Well, to interview him, we all survived.
- No, I wouldn't have--
- We all lived.
- I wouldn't have done it.
- No, it was good.
To interview him and he
interviewed us for this magazine.
It was all good.
- [Jimmy] Behind glass.
- No, no, it was in the same room.
(audience laughs)
And by the end of the interview he said,
you guys want to go see a movie?
We're like, sure, so I've
told this story before.
We go into see a movie,
and it was a horror movie.
- Yeah, it's a film of you
guys getting cut up in pieces.
- No, no, no, and it
was called The Descent,
a very scary, well-made movie.
And we go to see this movie,
and I'm in this theater
in Maine with Stephen King,
sitting next to Stephen King,
watching a horror movie, which
is like a dream life, right?
- [Jimmy] That's fantastic.
- So you're watching, and
every time someone was
really horribly killed, he
would go, that's awesome.
(audience laughs)
Like, he loved it so, he loved it.
- That makes so much sense.
(audience laughs)
- It was everything.
- That makes a lot of sense.
He's one in a million.
He's Stephen King.
I don't even want to--
- It was everything
going to a horror movie
with Stephen King should be.
(laughs)
It was fantastic.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
the The TF Nerd asked me to.
If there's someone you'd
like for me to profile
in a future top 10,
please check out the link
down in the description below,
and you can cast your vote
on who we should do next.
I also want to give a quick
shout-out to Terry Whalin.
Terry, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word and giving me
that five star feedback on Amazon.
I'm humbled, and I really,
really appreciate your support.
Thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love.
I'll see you soon.
(swooshes)
- Do you think there will be
a time when you'll be able
to, you know, create your
own idea for the big screen,
write your own script instead
of working on a franchise?
- I never expected to, that
the first thing I would direct
would be based on a television series.
It would be a sequel to
a series that was based
on a TV show.
When Tom Cruise gave me the
opportunity to make that movie,
you know, it was the
most surreal, amazing,
literally, to this moment I cannot believe
he asked me to direct that film.
It doesn't make sense to me.
Like, this still to me is like, what?
How did he let me do that movie?
So I got to direct a movie
that, you know, was of a genre
I adore, starred someone I was, you know,
the biggest actor in the
world, and the nicest guy ever.
I got work with the greatest crew ever.
It was like the dream situation.
So I did that movie for
many, many, many reasons,
not necessarily because
it was based on a TV show,
and I thought, wow, I
had gotten that chance.
I was so grateful.
And now I'll find some
original thing to do.
And I was working on
Star Trek as a producer,
and I was never a fan of
Star Trek to begin with.
But when I finally read the script
that we had been developing,
I thought, oh, my God.
This movie has got great
characters, amazing action.
It's incredibly emotional.
It's got this great
optimism I was referring to.
It's just, it's got spectacle
and intimacy, all the things
I love, and I thought well, this is nuts.
If I don't do this movie,
I'm going to regret it.
- All right, JJ.
I need to know.
What's the deal with the smoke monster?
- JJ, will you finally
bring back Jar Jar Binks?
- We are developing a Netflix
series called Binks and I.
- JJ, what does it feel like to be you?
- Awesome.
- JJ, what happened to
Darth Vader's grandchildren?
- Oh, George, this is great.
You tell me, man.
You made all this up.
- My question is, do you
think that we're all alone
in the universe or not?
- (laughs) This just got very grim.
No, I don't think we're
alone in the universe.
I don't.
But let's see what this is.
- I have a question for you.
I want to know why you
didn't cast me as Chewbacca?
I'm a little offended.
I think you know my reputation
and my ability to transform.
And not only can I grow hair,
I can grow hair all over my body, so--
- Next question.
- I'm a little disappointed,
but I'd love to know the answer to that
and why you haven't returned my calls.
- He was already cast.
I had nothing to do with it.
(swooshes)